with most of the world on fire plagued  by a deadly virus or on the brink of  nuclear war these are very scary times  many of us are keeping an eye on the  Doomsday Clock as it ticks closer and  closer to midnight and the end of human  civilization and now you can do it on  the go with Apple's new doomsday watch  just because you're going to brunch  doesn't mean you should be out of the  loop it keeps track of your steps and  heart rate so you can make the most of  these final days plus when the Doomsday  Clock hits midnight you'll be the first  to know with an 8 second warning oh I  get to home soon  the Apple doomsday watch buy stuff  because nothing matters  [Music]  you